[Music]
hey everybody what's going on it's
Friday night Tom couldn't go on without
his hat had to get my hat and it's
always like 30 seconds before the show
starts and he's like where's my hat I
forgot I didn't have it and get it you
Jen's telling me a story about Twilight
Zone Night Gallery just shows how well
he listens not yet why do I bother
talking I don't
know he didn't listen to a Goddamn word
I
say I didn't understand the
story it really wasn't that
complicated well I'll tell it to them I
we'll see if they understand it so as
you guys know if you watch my scare
salon videos I've been doing Night
Gallery like six episodes at a time I've
been doing Boris Carlo Thriller two but
you know I've kind of been tra trading
back and forth so I decided Well it's
about time to do another Night Gallery
one so I bought the box set like a while
back so I have all the episodes or so I
thought so I got to a point I'm on
season two and I'm working on episodes
um 7 through 12 and I W and I looked in
the box and the disc that supposedly had
those episodes on it was not in there
and I'm like what the [__] like CU it's
a bunch of discs you know what I mean
dis mising well let me finish the story
that's what I'm telling you quit trying
to he tries to like get the end I don't
know why that is so I'm like looking
through I looked through there like
three times I'm like maybe the set
didn't come with it you know maybe it's
like you know a mistake or whatever so
I'm like okay well [__] I have to do
something so I started watching I found
somebody had posted them on um Daily
Motion or something like that not on
YouTube because they would have got
pulled but it's hard to find them but
then like I got to season 2 episode 10 I
think it was and somebody had posted the
first story because it was two stories
on that episode somebody had posted the
first story but not the second one for
whatever reason so I was like well [__]
[__] me like what am I going to do now
because nobody had posted that second
story I couldn't find that [__] anywhere
and I said I'm just going to have to
fake it and like just read a plot
synopsis of it and just like pretend I
watched it or something like that so I
was like okay well maybe the discs were
in the box set but they fell out at some
point so I went in our bedroom and dug
through all the piles of DVDs and stuff
that are in there and sure enough yeah
two of the discs were in there loose
okay yeah so they must have like fallen
out of the box at some point because I
bought the whole box set and I then the
um it's one of those things where it's
like that plastic thing that holds the
discs in the middle and it's snapped out
of the spine yeah and the discs don't
really stay in there that good and so
the thing didn't close all the way so I
think what happened was like two of them
slipped out and I didn't notice but
thankfully I found them so now I'm just
going to be able to like watch them like
normal instead of trying to find some
illegal I remember once we were watching
that and we had it all open and those
discs were everywhere maybe they didn't
get put back
in I think that might have been what
happened because that's that occurred to
me cuz at first I thought oh well they
just [__] up and they didn't you know
put all they you know they just left
that disc out like it was a mistake but
then I thought well I'm going to go
search through that pile over there like
on the Shelf to see if it's in there and
indeed that's where it was so I have to
finish I didn't have time to finish
watching them today but hopefully over
the weekend like I said I was going to
put it up on Tuesday but we'll see how
that goes cuz it's going to be long cuz
it's six
episodes but uh but yeah Karen Lee said
a top hat would be cool you should wear
a top hat who Karen Lee I just said a
top who should have top you you should
have a top hat okay remember we were
talking about hats yeah cuz you had to
go get your hat yeah yeah I don't like
top hats that much you probably look
good in the top I don't think I've ever
seen you in a top hat it had to be crazy
then you wear no I guess not I had I
wore one for
prom really when I was in high school
yeah yeah okay yeah I wore [__] top
hat and
tails Swanky that was the [__] yeah yeah
yeah I
[Laughter]
bet no I thought remember a few years
back and I think this was even kind of
before we were officially going out or
anything but remember I dressed up for
Halloween as one of the jack Ripper
victims yeah like I had a Cutthroat and
I had the Victorian stuff on and
everything and you kind of went like
sort of half ass Jack the Ripper but I
don't remember I don't think you had a
top hat though but you had like a Jack
the rippery looking out yeah I don't
really remember that clearly yeah and
let me see uh yeah they mentioned Carl
Weathers died yeah he was old well yeah
but still in pretty good shape but it's
still sad though Anything Could Happen
well how old was he he was what maybe 76
77 around that probably
H seems to be a lot of that going around
yeah that's the age your dad died age
yeah that's about the age they di that's
the age my stepdad died yep he funeral I
just went to last week that's that's
about how long they die so yeah holy
crap was that almost a week ago yeah
that's crazy yeah it was last Saturday
me and Jen are going out tonight going
to mannequin Jen's looking great well
thank you y I got to showed his outfit
oh here we go yeah it's Jen's outfit
these are these pants you just got me
yeah I got her a lot of this
stand up J too too dark can't
see now belt all [__] up yeah
that you got little come out here in the
lights you see the boo boots yeah turn
sideway there you
go there there's Jen yeah well I I there
there I was before when I was sitting
okay made her that belt yeah that's
right you did
yeah don't fil me from underneath that's
still flat yeah yeah yeah no it's cute
just he doesn't know any
better boobs sticking out don't fil me
from
underneath man it's so easy why do you
do that it's so easy it's really not it
is so easy you can't see baby I can't
see you just push it in that's what I'm
telling you just push it in
baby yeah you like that don't you you
like that 75 grur Hammer said that's
always was so
old but not that old you know that's
about life expectancy for that
generation unfortunately yeah they don't
uh I I don't think they took care of
themselves as much
as you know well Carl probably pretty
took pretty good care of himself but
Carl was also steroid user sh happen in
his youth you know and he ended up kind
of burning a lot of the gas in their
tank and then when they get older they
can't really take any more of them
they've kind of damaged themselves
earlier on and they've kind of just
burned up kind of the the fuel in their
tanks and uh if they were to take some
they probably wouldn't get much of a
response
anyway um next going to be like Arnold
about time for Arnold to go hate to say
it but yeah he's getting up there yeah
and he hasn't been looking that good
past couple years you
know but you know he lasted a long time
yeah not as long as Jack LAN
like 97 he was in his mid mid to late
90s he didn't overdo
it Danny asked if I took the park bench
video from down from my Min vids yeah I
did I just I put it up for a but I
didn't love it you know the lighting was
too it was wrong the lighting was funny
and it's like the angle wasn't that
great I thought I looked like a hippo
and I was just kind of like I just I
wasn't into it like I kind of put it up
at first cuz I'm was like no it's fine
and I was just like uh I don't know yeah
it was okay it wasn't excellent yeah we
can make a better one and I thought
about it and then I was like I think I'm
going to take that down cuz I can make a
better one we can go back to that same
place God there goes the hair again part
of the problem was the lighting yeah it
was kind of like it washed her out and
it was late afternoon and we got like
weird shadows and stuff and it was kind
of the first time of doing the um the
outdoor stuff it's a good spot because
it's you know it's a really nice park
but if you go there at certain times
there's kind of like kind of secluded
places that are all open but there's
nobody there you know what I mean sobody
you as far as we know I mean I never I
didn't get a ticket or anything so I
guess nobody saw anything Florida
wouldn't give you any problem about that
I'm sure they wouldn't like I said as
long as there's no children like
watching or anything like that I don't
know if the people across the lake could
see anything there are houses over there
yeah people don't realize that yeah all
the all the old school Studios they're
they're in California but most of the
most of the scene for for for adult
content is here in Florida especially
around Miami and uh
um uh Tampa and there's uh quite a bit
of it here in Orlando I know some of the
people that are doing it here um but the
money is not with those Studios
it's private video sales only fans and
streaming thing is though is that the
big name girls will go through those
Studios
first to get a bunch of fans yes so when
they move into when they move into say
like private production
they have a fan base that can seek them
out right if you're just even if you're
just some goodlooking chick and you just
open up an only fans nobody's going to
follow it they don't know who they don't
know who to search for because there's a
lot of people doing that there's a lot
of hot chicks doing that you really have
to either have like a super specific
Niche or something or you already have
to have an existing fan base because
there's just so many that's kind of like
I said I like the way [__] is now that
it's like so much easier to produce your
own [__] and you own your own [__] and
own your own [__] but the dark side of
that is that everybody else is doing it
too so it's like a lot harder to stand
out and like make any money from that so
what it is it's always something that's
kind of attached to your other social
media Endeavors like a lot of the girls
that are doing say movie reaction videos
like Trixie blue she's some I think
she's Swedish or something or I think
she might be Swedish I don't remember um
she just makes cool little movie
reaction videos and if you want to see
her [__] spicy materials she she's
got a link to it uh and that wouldn't be
selling if she didn't
have other materials where she becomes
known of which is just doing just doing
movie reviews yeah yeah it's just it's a
good sideline to have but I would
recommend getting known in another way
because otherwise you're just like I
said unless you have some super specific
Niche that is underserved yeah then it's
going to be really really hard to stand
out because there's a 40 bajillion
million yeah like hot chicks and hot
dudes yeah doing this stuff yeah the
underserved niches are are bizarre
that's what I mean you're going to have
to go way way out there way out there
most or you have to like think of some
[__] that nobody thought of which good
luck with that good luck with that and
some of it's either illegal or [__]
possibly dangerous sure you know size
queen stuff and [__] putting
insertions and [__] weird [__] or
that weird dude that puts on a wet suit
and swims around in people's uh septic
septic tanks yeah that would be like
they got you know that's just that one
dude that's that one guy but that's the
kind of [__] that
[__] that would attract attention
there'd be some weird person looking for
that yeah you know like some dude who's
just [__] weird he wants to see girls
eat vomit just [__] you know what I
mean well there's there's an alarmingly
lot of that yeah not my thing but okay
the thing is with that and that goes
back to Two Girls One Cup yeah well it
was before that but that was just the
one that got super going back to that
the that video the the the fame of two
girls the thing is with a lot of that is
that you can fake it and it it's well
and it's constantly fake I kind of hope
they are two girls one cup is faked all
right but even if it wasn't it's still
gross because even if I know that it's
fake it still looks realistic and it
still makes me think comes out of her
butt but that's just like [__] like cake
batter and fing you know pudding and
stuff that they've made still but it's
like was still in her butt yeah but they
do but they pull things out of each
other's butts and put it in their mouth
all the time anyway that's true dick
comes out of the butt and if put it in
the mouth and [__] just yeah for some
reason that doesn't gross me out but I
mean it's a little bit gross but it's
not that gross yeah but that's they you
know they they're professionals they're
like acrobats you know what I mean to
them they've already gone gotten through
the the mental hurdles so that you know
cuz if it was me like anything having to
do with like [__] or vomit I'm just like
yeah yeah yeah like the whole time so
I'm just like I'm not going to be able
to like so what you could do with
um fakeing vomit is you could one fake
it with edits somebody vomits something
up then cut and then replace it with
something you replace it with another
kind of homade vomit that is don't go
too far in this direction or going to
that would be made out of food that kind
of looked like that I mean vomit is
technically made out of food another
thing is is they have some people that
some people that are trained you know
enough to where they can swallow
something and then bring it right back
up on
command they swallow a damn pool ball
and then bring them up yeah that's
talent and they can bring them up in
order and change the order that's that
dude from like Jim Rose circus was could
do that well the theoretically a person
could
make something that looked like a
[__] vomit material swallow it and
bring it right back up and then eat it
yeah wouldn't quite be vomit in the in
the way you would I mean technically it
would technically it would be but it
wasn't wasn't like a turkey dinner that
had been in there for a [__] hour
we're getting into vomit semantics what
what's that we're getting into vomit
semantics yeah yeah yeah we already know
that the Sid tracks they're always
demonetized so I'm just like no it's not
like that you know I'm not even worried
about you you could fake it you can fake
a lot of that I learned that my mom
watches these sometimes I don't know
about the sidetracks ones but she she
says she I don't know if she watches the
whole thing cuz like some of them are
kind of but she told me when we went in
um cuz after we went to my stepdad's
funeral last Saturday we went back to my
mom's house with all my siblings and
hung out with her for several hours and
she's like yeah I watched the beginning
of your videos just cuz I want to hear
your voice and I was like my mom's so
cute yeah but you know what now well now
now that she's single there's not going
to be any problems really she's cool
just just her husband was uptight about
a lot of [__] yeah I mean you know we'll
see how it goes I hope she's going to be
okay yeah cuz she's kind of out there by
herself I'm kind of worried about it but
yeah we're not that far I'm only an hour
away from her so and she said that after
she'd kind of gotten over everything and
everything like that I wanted her to
come visit cuz she hasn't she hasn't
seen the new house she came to our old
house for Thanksgiving yeah I got part
of my something I got part of my money
today but not all of it yeah more of it
come a lot more so yeah we got to start
thinking about a car yeah I want to buy
a new Kings siiz bed I'm looking we need
a new bed yo yeah I need a king siiz bed
I know this is maybe like a like a brag
yeah we broke our we broke I break the
[__] out of that it's broke all the [__]
that I eject into myself well we looked
under because Pooky hides under the bed
sometimes like if somebody comes over
all the supports are brand so we looked
under there looking for her one time and
all the supports are like yeah [__] B
like that and we're like get a better
quality bed I mean we got that
secondhand so and we've had it for
several years that mattress it's so
uncomfortable I really never liked that
bed and the bed's a little too small
it's it's a I think it's one of like a
large que I think it's a queen yeah it
might be a little bit bigger than a
queen when we lived at the old house we
had yeah when we lived at the old house
we had a king or a California king it
was a California I think it was the
California King which are like super
wide but it was one of those you know
like the sleep number but but it was
like offbrand sleep number so both sides
you could inflate them yeah like both
sides you can inflate them to like
different uh you know firmnesses or
whatever yeah and that was good but it
started to wear out but yeah we we also
got that secondhand so it's just like we
had it for a long time but then like it
would start to deflate and you'd have to
pump it back up and put the patch on it
yeah my side would deflate I'd be down
on the
[__] i' be waking up what are you
doing down in there yeah it was pretty
funny I fixed it though and I think like
well when we moved out of that house we
just left it we just left it well see
what it is and then we just took the bed
that was had been in the guest room in
the old house and used that but it's not
super comfortable the the base of it was
made out of particle board that all went
in together and it had it to support
everything and it had over the years
kind of warped through moisture and [__]
like that it just started to look kind
of Tatty and [__] I didn't trust the
damn um the inflatable parts of it
anymore and it had and it was around it
was surrounded in a bunch of foam and
the foam was starting to uh deteriorate
from a it was it was old it was old I
mean when we got it it was 10 years old
yeah it was old 10 years old when we got
and then uh but boy that was a [__]
nice bed though it was though it was
huge it was real nice it was huge I
remember when we first got it just
laying it and I was laying I was like
[__] you're way over there you fall
asleep B wasn't that good for sex though
it really wasn't it well because it we
kind of end up in the middle and that's
kind of where the thing we were like man
we're like down in a hole what the [__]
and I was always like I'm going to break
this
[__] but uh usually ended up [__] on
the floor yeah we kind of do that now
too well not always like this bed's okay
but we've kind of broken it take out a
living room and tear it down yeah we've
done that too yeah in front of the
window I'm sure the neighbors love that
hang titties open the window on the
second floor the neighbors are kind of
far away they would probably need
binoculars to see what was going
on but but we have done that too hey we
got a lot of room up here so got to got
to utilize it got to utilize it check
this out there's a lot up the street
and I saw an Audi TT sitting out there
looked good and I said I wonder what
they want for that but I'm not going to
stop in there so I
go on Facebook and search in my area for
an audt and that car came
up I ain't saying other people might
[__] buy it but it it is it's it's a
2020 excuse me it's a 2000 it's old
which is that's older than my car yeah
but and my car is 20 years old yeah but
it's very low low miles very low yeah
very low and they only want 35 for
it I'm like going but how much
aftermarket [__] are you going to have
to like add to that to make that like a
modern
car change stereo and get like a I want
probably put like a uh some kind of a
they have a stereos that have a screen
that you pull out and then it folds and
opens and it fits in a tape deck size
thing they have one of those that's a
couple hundred bucks might have to make
a wiring harness to get it to adapt and
then on an Audi T that fits behind a a
aluminum door that closes it all that
hides all that mhm um it's turbo it's a
[__] 1.8 I think 1.8 or or a 2.0 I
don't remember I think it might have
been a 1.8
turbocharged uh one and it was automatic
so you could drive it the thing is is
that U they have back seats but the back
seats are a joke it's just for insurance
purposes the back
seats you might be able to fit a child
back there I don't know you could
probably fit somebody but you'd have to
be behind the passenger you'd have to
move the passenger seat all the way I
mean it's not like we give other people
rides a great deal but it would be nice
to have that option if we needed that
also if we wanted to [__] in the back
seat cuz you there you go yeah no this
is a sports car the thing is it does
have know when that might Happ it does
have a big trunk and the bit the seats
low lay down to make the trunk even
better even bigger and some people
there's a kit that deletes those rear
seats and just leaves it into like a
hatchback so you have like a an open
space behind you that goes into the
trunk that's one thing that they'll
do
um but it's a sweet car they want 3500
for it it's only got uh I think it was
15,000 miles on it which you said 25 25
is at West okay that's that means that
car just sat or was just driven on the
weekends in this
area and they don't want much for it
because of a lot of people don't want
that here getting in and out of that is
fun [__] tough and and and like old
people are like oh oh I mean we're old
people too and so I get it you know I
mean and fat people can't drive them
they fat people can't get in and out of
them oh well that that lets out like 90%
of the people that live around here old
fat I saw a video of a of a of a of a
fat
20-year-old say saying he loved the car
go look how I have to get into it yeah
he had to sit down on his ass sideways
and then fold himself up to get into
into the door and move his belly over so
fat people can't drive
it I mean I used to be that's a European
car they don't a lot for [__] fat
people yeah they're like no yeah if we
don't play that we don't play that yeah
this is a race car go and [__] walk
[__] of Man TT okay and it's
it's a turbo version but it's automatic
which you see that's good for you you
can drive it I don't care if it's
automatic or not like I said I can drive
a manual but I haven't for a long time
one and two I would rather not my first
car was a manual yeah and I hatte and
the parts are all available for that car
because it's it's it's Avail all a bunch
of other platforms like Volkswagen uses
those parts I think even BMW has some of
those
parts I think it's souped up Volkswagen
Rabbit I think I think it's rabbit or
Pat which I think might be a
rabbit ganther says I was considering
having my wife take a cattle prod to my
t and putting on Reddit think there'd be
an audience oh there's an audience
audience for just getting kicked in
honestly I would watch that there's a
audience for getting kicked in nut I
love yeah the what do they call that the
the ball torture I love those send me up
the wall I saw some my video Jim was
watching she's laughing I'm and I was
just like cackling the whole time no man
they have a whole thing he a little bit
like they'll just like they have a whole
board situation where they stick the
dude's balls like up in there and then
like some chick with like with like
really severe like high heels come step
on him and I'm just like look at that
holy [__] they're not stepping on his
scoat they're stepping on the testicles
and I'm like I'm just like are they
going to pop those I got to go and then
I'm like I got to watch this yeah J J's
loving that [__] Jen make a good
dominatrix I probably would actually
because it's like I have a hard time um
pretending to be nice to people that I
don't like but if somebody came and paid
me to just be like a total cun to them
oh I would I would be really good at
that I'd be really good at that I'm not
a total CT in real life I'm actually a
really person but you aren't I yeah
no you're friendly to people you're
friendly to people but no you don't have
much patience for for the average person
that's true that's true the average
person around here you don't have
patience for him no but I don't say
anything to their face I'm not going to
that's what I meant I meant I'm even
though I'm thinking about man i' like to
murder you right now but I'm not going
to like say that out loud or do anything
you know what I mean I just keep it all
to myself because that's not cool I know
that's not cool but you know what I mean
I would be a good dominatrix though I
think yeah Mur Hornet said I remember
trying to get out of going to school as
a kid and put some egg in my mouth and
acting like it was like I was vomiting
she didn't fall for it just looked like
partially chewed eggs nice try though
Val
effort um Ben says poor Pooky might get
squashed what like in the
bed she hasn't got squashed so far yeah
she'll be all right and she sleeps up on
the bed she likes to sleep well either
on Tom's chest yeah that's or she sleeps
between my feet
yeah and then I feel really bad cuz like
I'll wake up and I'll be like hey I
really like to like roll over and sleep
on my side but I can't because she's
there so I have to right on my chest and
she'll be looking at me yeah yeah and if
and if I don't pet her she goes hey hey
pet yeah but pet me come on Daddy she
yeah then she like I can't do she's so
cute though you can't say no we tried to
get Bambi like to come up on the bed but
she won't she's like she seems to be
like scared of the bed she'll somebody
told her no about the bed long time
maybe and it's like like she'll come in
she'll come in the room she'll come on
the floor like she doesn't mind if like
Tom picks her up and carries her around
and stuff like that but Tom will pick
her up and bring her in and put her down
on the bed petting her and she's and she
be like no and she just like runs and
jumps off so I think that maybe wherever
she was before somebody was like
throwing her throwing stuff at her yeah
or like like telling her to get off the
bed yeah I don't care if the cats are on
the bed yeah we eat on the bed we do all
kind of stuff on the bed cats can sit on
the bed it's fine they're not dirty
um John Smith says loving The Look by
the way thank you very much yeah we're
going out later going to mannequins
tonight we'll see how that goes yep it's
been better actually when we went last
Friday I don't know if we said but it
does seem like security is tightened
security has tightened a lot they you
know they charge a cover charge now um
and a lot of the younger goth crowd have
sort of taken over over yeah which I'm
all for well it's around midnight the
Deuces come in and the
[__] DJ freaks out when they're out
there and they don't know how to dance
and that there's too many of them there
he goes douchebags cannot be on the
dance get off go Club if you're a
douchebag get the [__] off the dance
floor and I love the way that like the
douchebags like look at each other like
and we're like you he's talking about
you you can't dance a little dance floor
it's a little dance floor and you you
don't know how to dance and they just
kind of either that or they just kind of
go out there stand there yeah they don't
they stand there or they don't know how
to dance and they're like you're you're
not you're not with the theme of tonight
you know what I mean come some other
come New Wave night or come on one of
the [__] other night yeah cuz they
started doing a new wave night on
Saturday I think they're trying to like
pull people away from Barbarella yeah
which they might but I mean the two
clubs are so far
apart um that I don't think there's
going to be and Barbarella has such a
loyal fan base cuz I love their Saturday
still I don't love it as much as when it
was downtown cuz that club is like
iconic and it's you know they don't have
it anymore but I still like that
Saturday I like the crowd I like the
vibe I like all that kind of stuff you
know what I mean but mannequins has been
getting better because the thing about
it is that I think the problem before
was that it took a long time like nobody
would show up early cuz we're nerds like
we'll show up there like you know half
an hour after they open or something and
like hardly anybody's in there cuz I you
know I like to kind of get start Ed like
I like to dance when nobody else is
around in my way you know what I mean so
um so I think what happened was that
because there weren't a lot of people in
there like just these kind of douchy
people would do would wander in from
other places be like hey there's nobody
in here and then they would start acting
ass you know what I mean and then like
other douchebags would come in and go
hey there's those people acting ass we
are also going to act ass so they would
do that and and then like people like us
be there and be like man everyone's
acting ass we should leave you know what
I mean but if you get all the kind of
gothy people there early and they all go
out on the Dance Floor then people come
in and they're like oh okay this isn't a
place for us yeah and then they either
go out back and shut the [__] up or they
leave so I think it's better because you
need like strengthen numbers you know
what I mean you need them to come in and
be like oh well maybe I can't act ass
here because this is not it's not like
full of douchebags already acting ass
you know lot there there's there's this
thing in mainstream culture where they
they they do not come equipped with club
culture and this isn't just me saying
this there are people that own clubs
I've even heard the [__] on on on on uh
YouTube they're saying how [__] up the
clubs are in some of the other big
cities like in California New York and
that area that some of those big clubs
are [__] up now because the the
clientele shows up and they don't know
how to behave in a club they they don't
have a club culture what they you know
they don't go
regularly so what they do is they just
get on the dance floor and they all get
behind one another and take selfies on
the dance floor yeah but they don't
dance they're just on this going hey
look I'm at a club everybody on my
social media I'm so popular look I can
dance well that's exactly and they they
can't dance I'm having fun yeah yeah
yeah just like put the [__] phone
down get a drink I leave my phone in the
trunk of my car yeah score a drug dealer
or something [__] get some drugs yeah
do do at a [__] club right go get
laid give up some ass all right do
something have a good time yeah you know
it doesn't involve looking at you you're
right stop put the [__] phone
away all right I don't even take my
phone into the club with me I really
don't I put it in I put it in the trunk
of my car so they're they're very
touristy and what what really used to
irk me and [__] Jen and send us up
the [__] wall is when they would come
up to me and Jen and ask to take
pictures with us like [__] no no what
I'm not Tigger at Disneyland okay that's
right all right this is not Disney I'm
not a [__] Disney character no one is
paying me to be here and get pictures
Tak back off of my coolness on your lame
ass [__] timeline all right that's
exactly what they're trying to do yeah
you do not hang out with me I would
never let you hang out with me get your
[__] you [__] Nory ass up with
that [__] exactly that's you know no
it's girls it's not guys it's girls it's
almost always girls it's always girls
now some sometimes it's dudes but 95% of
the time it's girls yeah a lot of the
guys know better and then they get mad
they get mad when I say no yeah like no
like they're you know I'm just like no
thanks like I'm not a super [__] about
it uh there times there's but well it
depends how they approach yeah it
depends how they approach if they come
up and they're nice about it and I'm
just like nah I don't really want to do
that and they're just like fine and they
walk off okay cool but if keep
persisting cuz some of them are a little
bit drunk and [__] like that then I'm
going to get then I'm going to get upset
and there was one time this is back at
this is back at iar a long time ago me
and Jen were up at the bar we were
pretty loaded and me and Jen were
probably this is probably at the time
where me and Jed are
[__] we're we're probably we not a
couple at this time but we were we were
[__] all right and we were probably
kind of pissed off remember that we were
up there at the club and some dude kept
wanting to talk to us and fin finally I
was just like look man we're we're
having a conversation here you know we
don't really want to talk to you but
this is how you meet people how do you
meet people if you don't talk to people
how are you going to make and I said
[__] I know plenty of people we know
everybody here we we have friends I
don't need we're [__] busy okay right
we don't we don't need you as a friend
you know which is that that that blew
his [__] mind but yeah it's just like
did he think we didn't have any friends
other than him and like he was doing us
a favor yeah he was doing us a favor and
[__] that's what kind of got me I'm W
guy or anything he just was
not he he was he looked decent he was
actually even kind of dressed decent he
kind of looked cool just he wasn't a
regular I don't remember what yeah I
never seen before he was from somewhere
else I mean iar and he wouldn't take a
hint you get people that would come in
like you know just random ass people but
85% of the people in there you knew who
they were you knew who they were like if
even if you didn't know who their their
names you're just like oh yeah that's
that [__] that com we know
everybody hanging out with you know what
I mean yeah cuz it's a soap oper yeah we
know everybody he hangs out with we yeah
even if we didn't know that guy we knew
somebody that knew that guy that [__]
that guy or something or was related to
that guy or something so if you come in
without any straight cred or any history
you say hey what's up how you doing nice
to meet you okay look and that's what's
G to happen yeah unless there's
something that really stands out about
you like you're [__] dress fantastic
that is a [__] goth outfit where are
you from oh okay that explains it it's
that kind of sh you look great man then
all of a sudden cuz you're in the you're
in the scene you're visited that type of
from somewhere else yeah like that's
totally fine totally I'm not I don't I'm
not mad about that I just get mad about
people that come up and like have this
they kind of have this sort of audacity
to well you should be privileged to talk
to me and I'm like who the [__] are you
though I've never seen might sound
[__] funny to a person who doesn't
really know us or know the scene or to
we came from a time when people really
looked down their [__] noses at you
all the time yeah all right and then
over time the goth scene kind of became
un cool yeah all right it was not cool
it was not cool at the very beginning no
so we always kind of were on guard about
Outsiders well and I had friends that
got beat up yeah for looking like that
right and then what would happen is is
that you'd have somebody who was just
Normie as Normie could be that [__]
has never been to this club doesn't know
anybody from this club and they think
that they can just step in and have you
kind of serve them because in a way they
see that they think that they're above
you that's what I mean I'm slumming down
in here with these gos yeah that's the
impression that I get that's why we get
offended get real offended like I'm not
[__] your servant you know I mean I
don't mean to be a like I said I don't
mean to be a [__] or anything like that
but we've experienced a lot of that
before where people think one you're
either a performing monkey or you're
you're there you're trash you're yeah
that too and you're just there for your
edification it's like we should be
privileged that you're speaking to us
you know what I mean so I do get that
impression the ones that think that
you're trash tend to be like yepy jock
boy kind of oh yeah big time they kind
of think they think that they're of a
higher social order cuz they think it's
still high school EV and that uh you're
you're poor you're poor so they could
they could treat you like [__] yeah they
want to [__] your girlfriend
though or that kind of [__] and the
girls want to [__] some of those dud
with those goth dudes but the thing is
that sling all right so we're kind of
like they're kind of treating us like
[__] like we're second or third class
citizens yeah you know what I mean it's
better than it was yeah it's not they
know better now a lot of but that took
decades yeah but for a long time it was
like that yeah that's why we're real
that's why goth girls are real still
especially ones as old as my ass is um
are real reluctant about like Normie
dudes that come and like dud because
there's a weird fetish about it there's
a weird and they do tend to think of you
as like oh she's this trashy [__] that
will do anything cuz look at her so some
of the porn stars are Goths so po goth
girls are porn stars yeah you know they
they have a perception of goth girls is
like freaky they're all into like weird
fetishes and all this other kind of
stuff some of them are but um some of
them aren't and it's like even if they
are they aren't they're not going to do
the [__] with you that's for sure yeah
that's another
thing uh a lot of those porn stars and
everything you would think that they
would just be [__] real easy no even
them would be hard to get yeah um
they're working when they do that yeah
you know that's what I mean that's a job
yeah and they don't like you basically
they don't your money and they're
probably have a lot more walls up than
normal people would because they're used
to getting get all this attention and
getting [__] on all the time and being
seen as like lesser because of what they
do yeah so they're probably like super
guarded yeah in a in in a weird way a
lot a lot of those porn stars would be
hard to get they would be hard to on a
personal level and then the thing is
that you may not want to get that
because they got so much other [__]
going on one if their Studio of por
Stars they work a lot they're not really
in a position to date and some of them
are escorting because that's where a lot
of times where the money is coming from
a lot of money and you know then you ask
do you want to have a girlfriend who's
escorting or making video I mean some
dudes don't mind that well some dudes
don't mind that at first it also depends
on the age level me once the rubber hits
the road and you actually see what it's
like on a day-to-day basis yeah you know
you might not like it as
much like I said it is just a job and a
lot of women can compartmentalize I
wouldn't be able to but a lot of people
can um so you know but I can see how a
dude want wouldn't want to data no yeah
girl like that because he would never
have the feeling of exclusivity yeah and
and then it's like and this is special
like in right yeah and then all of a
sudden you know what I mean well I got
to go to work but what do you got to do
today oh well [__] gang bang and he's
oh [__] yeah and he's not doing this
like 10 dudes got to now if he's doing
this for a living that's then he
probably understand like oh yeah well
that's why a lot of porn I'll help out
end up with other porn stars because
they understand that's really the best
situation the nature of the job and
they're not hung up about it they're
like cars basically they're in the same
scene and and the thing is is that she's
screwing dudes that are in that same
scene that he knows they're friends of
his and he's just like oh well that's
okay that dude's okay those dudes have
wives that kind of [__] could happen too
you know so so it's like so I can see
how it's much easier yeah because
everybody understands where everybody's
coming from if you had to like date
somebody outside that yeah yeah it would
be kind of hard to the problem is this
though a lot of the porn girls don't
want anything to do with the guys that
are in porn because a lot of times they
see them as on the lower level
especially if they're [__] because a
lot of them are mopes yeah you know what
I mean well they're not the main draw
like unless it's gay porn yeah and
they're kind of lowlevel guys and those
dudes may be on the escorting too for
dudes so make so they but they put those
dudes on lower level they they can do
with them [__] and then like the
topnotch male porn performers are in the
gay scene you make more money though
they're going to make a lot more money
not going to lie straight dudes don't
make a lot they're not making in
straight porn because they're like I
said they're not the main attraction
yeah the dudes the straight dudes that
are in that industry what they're trying
to do is they're trying to become
producers to have enough money to
[__] have their own company but
that's all kind of going out the back
door because social media is destroying
all
that you
know it's not like Studio [__] doesn't
it's not as profitable girl why would a
girl want to work for a studio after
she's already
famous because she doesn't own that
material she gets paid once to do that
scene and then and then the money's gone
right and maybe it's 700 maybe it's
1,200 maybe it was 500 then she never
sees a dime off that if that was on her
site she put she would just keep making
like every time somebody bought it right
yeah then she would still make money
from it like I said I like that a lot
better but it's harder to get noticed
that's the that's the downside that's
the downside but it is much easier to
like own your own material which what
are they saying down here are we way
behind are way behind Ben says not being
cool was sort of the whole point wasn't
it as as far as the god scene um yeah
well I don't know if we really I didn't
really think about it as being cool the
the only the only people I wanted to be
cool to were other God people no let me
let me word this the right way no the
god scene was always cool just wasn't
cool it by the mainstream standards it
had its own definition of what cool was
we have our whole own we have our own
rules we have our own it's a whole
different thing it was a subculture yeah
it's by the very definition of the one
it has its whole different Norms its
whole different everything like uh okay
mainstream culture jock culture
R&B rap culture all of that is basically
considered to be [__] ultimately
uncool from a goth point of view that's
like man that's the worst yeah it's
super uncool well that's most of the
especially jock culture super unol and
then like [__] country would be
really uncool oh very [__] we like
Old Country though I like I like Johnny
Cas yeah yeah some of it some of it most
of us like Johnny because some country
can actually fall within the definition
of goth yeah yeah yeah like like Nick
Cave he did a whole album of murder ball
and [__] contr but and he does go
yeah yeah yeah so like I said people
recognize because it's all like it's a
bummer right they talk about like just
like shitty like philosophical kind of
[__] we love that kind of stuff right so
they're not as the thing about goth is
and I don't know about young ones
nowadays I don't know that many that are
that young but back in the day the
younger ones are like we were more
they're more retro yeah they like a lot
a a much wider variety of music than
people would um think they're listening
to Old Death Rock they're yeah well like
I said I like all the goth music and
Industrial music and stuff like that but
I like a lot of different kind of music
I like rockabilly I like class some
classical I like like all kind of
different [__] it just has to have a
certain [__] Vibe too yeah if it has
a certain Vibe I'm all into it I even
like some kind of mainstreaming kind of
music yeah but you know like [__]
certain [__] Gavin Friday songs just
you know that's mainstream gay stuff I
still like and like I you know I like a
lot of classic rock and stuff like that
you know I like a lot of that having
Frid of [__] it's just not
notable pet shot boys that was some more
gay stuff I thought it was good [__]
eraser some of that was really
good and that was that was like that was
like gay club music that was like gay
club music yeah but they were good man
[__] gays have a [__] no
understand good gays I'm gonna say that
because they got bad gays good gays are
the [__] Kings of club culture they
they understand oh yeah well well why do
you think so many goth Knights are at
gay clubs yeah there's a huge cross huge
crossover there's a huge
crossover um but yeah um let me see hold
on murder Hornet said not going to lie
in high school days and few years after
Goths were
weird I feel like Goths were weird until
when did it super go mainstream was it
Tim Burton that did it or was it 9inch
nails that did it n Marilyn Manson [__]
probably thrust it into the main stream
and he was not really a good example nah
friends of ours know him I've run into
him well he grew up around here I ran up
to I ran Mr Brian Warner yeah I ran into
him French Quarter in New Orleans him
and uh [__] Trent resner yeah
yeah [__] was [__] weird too this
[__] Ferrari he's a little weird yeah
I like n Inch Nails I don't love 9 Inch
Nails I saw 9in
Nails before they got big they opened
for Peter Murphy actually I saw him in
St Pete in
uh what the [__] was it in mafy theater
whatever that was Trent was kind of
Trent was kind of a mainstream type dude
who kind of got into the industrial
scene and mixed rock with it to bring it
to the mainstream but I have to say 9in
Nails the quality was very good he he
yeah I like a lot of that [__] their
first album is [__] great yeah I
bought that well actually I didn't buy
it
someone taped it for me called Petty
Hate Machine I think called Pretty Hate
Machine Prett Hate Machine someone taped
it for me because I was broke I never
own my friend Dave actually recorded it
for me he bought it but the quality was
good but I in those days when that came
out I saw it as a knockoff it was a
knockoff it was a it was a mainstream
knockoff the real thing at that time
would have been skinny puppy real indust
I liked them but I kind of thought yeah
they they just kind of sound like a
mainstream version of skinny PU
the real thing was skinny puppy us used
to see them in Detroit when I used to go
to [__] the shelter and [__]
Andrews Hall they played there they
played at uh City
Club and they were just across the
street in Canada or just across the the
the the bridge in Canada they were I
think they were
from Montreal I think is where they were
from don't hold me to that but I think
they were from
Montreal and they would hang out with
some of the same clubs that I would go
to that was my very early days of
[__] goth in the late 80s when I was
living in
Detroit and uh it was a wild time it was
that was like when the goth scene was
something out of The Crow and the crow
was supposed to be taking place in
[__] Detroit and yeah it was kind of
like
that it was just a weird time I could do
a whole [__] show on me living in the
damn cattle slaughter house it's like
something out of Batman used to drive my
car into the cattle l and bring it up
into my apartment pull it off into the
[__] Slaughter
Bay and then the room layout make any
damn sense yeah it was only 350 bucks a
month I like [__] Batman like Liv
that right now yeah and I had a Merc
look how much money I had a 1972 Lincoln
Mercury monteo that was totally rusted
out and I spray painted all over it like
rat skulls and [__] I had a couple of
mingas [__] strapped to the [__]
front hood [__] Shogun Warriors and
[__] I love it yeah it's [__] I don't
think you ever told me that before I'm
like oh my God that's rat yeah yeah yeah
yeah I was wearing [__] old [__]
blue dark blue [__] Air Force trench
coat wool trench coat that they had you
know and [__]
um uh engineer boots with [__] rings
in the side like those wor that and
[__] pants and you know black pants
and black sweaters and [__] you know you
couldn't find real cool goth clothes
yeah it was hard back then yeah either
to make your own [__] or you had to buy
[__] at the thrift shops and alter it if
you knew how to do that and I was poor
working on my own spring engineering
making car door parts for [__] Fort
we working on a Ford subsidary place
it's making about eight bucks an hour
but I was only
part-time and uh well then 350 a month
was good then because back then yeah but
I didn't have a roommate I didn't really
have a full-time
girlfriend and I saidu you just had a
parttime girlfriend no I had goth girls
that were trying to [__] you several
part-time girlfriend yeah well I had
these goth girls that would try to
[__] just leech off of me you know
and try to live in the room you let him
stay for a little while and no you guys
you guys aren't helping me pay anything
gotm yeah I'd meet him at [__] um
City Club
yeah Thomas tell me that last night
because I was kind of teasing him about
STDs and he's like after all of those
women which we discussed she okay yeah
which we discussed on the other show
that in the triple digits it's got they
weren't women they were girls too well
and girls too but yeah when well you
were young too don't don't anybody get
the wrong idea but you know what I mean
everyone was teenagers of the same age
sure but um you were like yeah I never I
never got an STD though no I never got
any I had good practices see he had good
sanitary practi good sanitation
practices that was during the time of
AIDS served you well well yeah everybody
was like freaking out of back then
probably like maybe people were more we
condoms and [__] wash my [__] right
up [__] right after anything I didn't
let any damn bodily fluids stay on me I
mean I I did that too so but like I said
I I didn't really I didn't [__] nearly
as many people I kind of made sure that
girls were shaved so they weren't hiding
anything no
[__] that was a good thing is goth
chicks even back in the days were shaved
yeah so it was you could you you you
could assess the state of health a lot
we just like I think a lot of goth
chicks were just kind of like [__]
hair man yeah well it just hair was
shave it hair was nasty shave off your
eyebrows shave off your [__]
everything let's you know it's easier to
maintain y if you just shave the [__]
all off I got most of my head shaved 80s
90s and [__] goth goth girls were the
best man they were they were real cool
what about me f yeah yeah I mean I grew
up at that time too though the problem
was
this I was young I wasn't making enough
money when you're in your late teens and
early 20s you cannot compete with guys
who are in their 30s they're making a
lot of [__] money so you can't keep
any women they take them from you
doesn't matter what a player you are
they just come and go you have a better
chance actually hooking up with an older
chick that that the other guys don't
want cuz she's too old I guess then her
30s I had I should have gone that way
they probably would have helped me yeah
you probably should have the other ones
are just parasiting off but I guess it
didn't OCC but they're not interested in
you yeah 30-year-olds are go chair chick
she's not interested in you back in the
80s but um it would they might be a
little bit more interested today but
isn't it funny like that you're talking
about 30-year-old goth chicks like they
were old like they were old yeah and I'm
like 21 years older than now yeah well
they seemed old when you were 19 yeah
when you're young yeah it seems like 30
is like super old it's really not those
are kids now yeah it's yeah that could
that could be my kid yeah
nowadays um kayen hickin says I've seen
interviews with a couple of people in
the adult industry some of them are
really smart and nice people but above
all they're very honest I kind of feel
like you sort of have to be you have to
at least you yourself if if do that for
a living um it kind of even just like
the little foras we've made into it was
just kind of like I don't know it does
do a lot about like with your mindset
you know like I feel like it changed a
lot of my attitudes and stuff like that
I don't know how to explain it exactly
well I had a a background in in theater
so I understand about what a performance
is like it's a performance in a certain
way soon soon as you know you're making
something and you're going to sell it
there's an amount of performance to it
which kind of G makes it gives it s of
kind of a sense of unreality yeah you're
doing it but not really yeah I mean you
are but it's not right
um the problem with the adult industry
and making all this is that you have
very
young women getting involved in this
with probably unrealistic
expectations and about how it's going to
go um they don't know how to
disassociate themselves they don't have
any like Say drama background or theater
background so they kind of reality and
fantasy might be merging into the same
thing there might be a lot of conflicts
because they may not really want to be
doing this is that they have to do it
because for economic reason reasons so
they're being affected by what they're
doing probably maybe negatively because
it's taking an emotional toll on them
yeah um which that's not good
um they then sometimes aren't real aware
of how it could especially if they get
involved with studio type porn they
don't realize how that's going to affect
them in terms of their love lives later
on uh it's going to limit your limit you
to certain kinds of guys guys now if
you're if you're a mature person who's a
little bit older who understands all
these ramifications and [__] and you're
still willing to do it then you can
process this a lot better young people
just in general cannot process reality
very well they don't really can't really
proc they can't really Pro uh process
ramifications if you're a young girl
getting involved in this [__] you're not
going to be dating young guys cuz young
guys aren't looking for that you might
be able to date an older guy but he's
going to going to be a veteran or he
might be somebody from the from the
industry then
is
it's that's all I can say about it
really I guess um that that's probably a
good way to put
it there's ramifications to all this
[__] now once you pass
30 the penalties for doing this kind of
stuff for your woman the social
penalties are actually far less the
older you get the less penalty there is
for because you have a lot less to lose
and also the older you get like the less
[__] that you give yeah the the less
mental stress that is so it's win-win
yeah because you know you know who you
are yeah you know that that you're
creating a product and that you know
that this isn't a big deal this is all
[__] you've done before anyway it's not
going to affect you personally because
maybe you were already married maybe
you've already had kids you know what I
mean you you've passed all that state of
life I wouldn't recommend this for I
wouldn't recommend
that that um
line of work for a for a woman under 30
really the 20s is the time you're
supposed to be kind of like being normal
and [__] you know we'll do what we
needed to do like getting College
starting your career like getting
married if you want to do that having
kids if you want to do that like that
kind of stuff right just that your value
to that industry is [__] late teens
and in your 20s and that's the prime
time to [__] you up you're not really
smart enough for that and you haven't
[__] done [__] in life yet and having
a background like that could prevent it
you're not going to meet the man in your
dreams you're not going to [__] have
the [__] kid in the family house and
the [__] white picket fence and the
dog because you're just that kind of guy
who can help you do that he's not there
he's gonna be interested in somebody
else who's not doing that
yeah let's see um Ben says it's not gay
if you do it for money it's not gay if
you do it for money Ben damn I didn't
know that I mean it's not doors well
that's what I'm saying like it's not
really what you're into you're just
doing for cash it's gay though it's gay
I don't know I'm not worried it's gay if
you did it for money you're still gay
I'm not worried about it you just have
to be the kind of man that can absorb
and say yeah that [__] was gay I don't
give a [__] well yeah that's what I mean
it's just kind of like don't don't worry
about it don't put yourself in a box man
they got dudes in the intelligence
community that do that not gay but well
[__] a dude to get
information they evidently they said in
the James Bond books he was like that he
was a sex op operative too he was
getting information by any means
necessary well some dudes just want
money by any means
necessary which I couldn't do it though
I don't
think although we did that [__] one
mental experiment what if it's the Saudi
[__] Prince who's offering me [__]
$300,000 for a [__] weekend me and
these other dudes are [__] Jenny be
like you better pack your bags and tape
it see what I would do is I would
[__] I would I would [__] like I
said you'd make me go yeah I would make
you go I would just expect go Jen's
going to go [__] i' be packing the
back [__] but uh the that's a lot of
money 300,000 man that's what I mean
it's a lot of [__] if I have to go
through that [__] so to you 100,000 is a
lot what I would do is I would play Mind
Games okay to try to take the upper hand
position in it and I would [__]
become the ultimate leather daddy and go
down there just to be a [__] I'm
gonna take some ass off these [__]
dudes yeah be like that yeah I try to
[__] be in in the top position that's
that's how and then I would just go and
[__] dance and put on the [__]
best show I could probably you'd be good
at it I think yeah probably would be
yeah but it' beat money yeah yeah I mean
for that much money that's a [__] a lot
of money I'd put up with a lot of
[__] you could that's enough to
start a [__] business there murder
Hornet said I can't see Tom in the1st
being a goth oh no they're [__] Goths
on1st time my sad leader was a goth yeah
s Smith we were out everywhere we were
in the [__] we were in the [__]
desert desert Patrol in [__] Sinai
the Sinai Peninsula riding around in our
[__] little un vehicle [__] doing
operations with the awax planes watching
us going through our Patrol route we
were playing the disintegration album in
the [__] out in the Egyptian desert
[__] blazing [__] Sun hot dry
beautiful though man [__] I love the
desert I could live in the Middle East
[__] easy I like that
place
I no we were [__] jamming man listen
to goth music I think we had a super
chat okay I was way behind Okay yeah uh
thank you very much Jeffy art send us a
Super Chat Jeffy waiting for my pizzas
at the restaurant and had you guys on
speaker the little old Italian ladies
were blushing to Tom's insight to
porn oh my God that's such that's that's
awesome yeah don't I wouldn't advise uh
playing our show out loud in a family
establishment I'm just saying yeah you
never know what's going to I'm going to
say I mean yeah I never know what I'm
going to say either especially although
I need another drink man okay that was
only my first one time is it I mean we
are it's only 8:30 we still got like an
hour okay before we got to go anywhere
okay uh let me see hold on uh Victor
says it's hard to get an STD from
pegging just uh just a pro
tip just a pro tip murder Hornet said
why do girls say they got a piss before
SE do they before sex do they they
usually tell you now I remember like in
health class they told you to pee
afterward like to kind of clean [__] out
and like you know clean yourself up and
everything but the only time I have to
pee before that is if I just woke up and
you know I got to pee from like the
night before like and then like Tom
starts like molesting and he's like
pushing on my abdomen and I'm just kind
of like you're pushing on my bladder I
really got to be right now that's the
only
time but I don't I don't know why
beforehand maybe well it might be
because they just say oh got to pee cuz
they got to go like clean themselves up
make sure they're make sure they're
fresh I guess I mean that's that's what
I would think cuz then you just like
make sure you don't like smell weird or
something I don't know that's just my
that's just my uh
Theory does sex make a woman go to the
bathroom pressure something on the
bladder no
um no like I've never really had that in
particular but like I said sometimes I
kind of had to pee beforehand and then
like after I was like okay now I really
got to pee you know what I mean but
usually if it's cuz Tom is just kind of
like he'll wake up and he'll be like
start molesting and I'm just kind of
like dude I haven't even gone to the
bathroom yet it's like I really really
have to be right now and he's like
pushing on it so yeah like that's so
that there's that but I don't I don't
think that's a general thing I don't
know um let me see hair hair it's all
the same in the middle
yeah I just I don't know I like I just
kind of
prefer not I I kept kept it for a long
time and then finally I was like you
know what it's just it's such a pain to
like trim it and like maintain it and
[__] it was the same reason I shaved my
eyebrows off in the end because I was
just like I just got sick of tweezing
them like into a shape I was like [__]
this I'm just going to shave them off
and I'll just draw them back on wherever
I want them you know what I'm saying
it's just much easier much easier the
only thing that's kind of that kind of
sucks is that I can't really go around
without makeup on
unless I want people looking at me like
does that girl not have any eyebrows you
know what I mean I'm kind of used to it
and Tom's kind of used to it and I don't
think I look that weird like without
makeup on with no eyebrows but I always
kind of have a thing where I'm just like
I'm in store I'm like is everybody
looking at me because I don't have any
like they're trying to figure out like
what's wrong with my face cuz I don't
have any eyebrows like I look like an
alien or something but I don't know
maybe they don't maybe maybe it's fine a
lot of times too like what I'll do is
I'll put put glasses on because I was
like then people won't notice you know
that I don't have eyebrows if I have
glasses on soz it'll kind of cover up
that area but
yeah I did go to Dollar General once
without any makeup on because I just
couldn't be bothered but I don't usually
I don't usually leave the house without
makeup
on uh let me
see Hi Desert said
uh do you think there were more Goths in
the Army than in the Marines do goth
athletes exist I mean I kind of feel
like goth everything exists it's that
you just don't see much of it and
especially if it's something where
people have to wear a particular thing
so you wouldn't
really notice it you know what I mean
unless they had like a crazy hairstyle
or something like that or like weird
piercings or something you wouldn't
really notice and even then it's kind of
hard to tell nowadays because a lot of
people have that that
aren't you know it's not like it used to
be
where um you know a lot of people have
tattoos and a lot of people have
piercings and a lot of people have weird
haircuts and stuff like that so it's
just not like you can't really tell like
you used to be able to especially you
don't see the full Ensemble you
know say murder Hornet you uh you send
my [__] out yet need my
shipment my drug shipment Tom needs
drugs I need my drugs bro that's my
[__] time needs drugs murder Hornet he's
my [__] Viagra connection give me
some that Mexican Viagra time needs the
Viagra yeah you don't really need the
Viagra but I love that [__] he loves the
Viagra I love Viagra you take that how
about how often do you take that I don't
even know once every couple days yeah it
depends on how much you got to have he
just always taking that yeah it [__]
works good with steroids
too cuz it [__] it just gets into all
your system real well it's good for
[__] pre-workout and stuff shit's
[__] good man he's just always
looking for I take all kinds of weird
[__] he's always looking for [__]
yeah aren't you Tom yeah I mean yeah I
like anything if I know what it is and
then I trust it I go yeah okay I know
what that is I know how it works I'll do
research on it man we didn't get I'm not
just doing [__] willy-nilly everything's
to a plan say we didn't get anything
today you slept too late no you didn't
get late no n you slept too late no I
might throw it down we'll see we'll see
how it goes I'll [__] [__] you at the
club all right then what do you go to do
enjoy it [__] we got places we can go
in the club well actually last week we
own that place we went to the bathroom
we go we went employees bathroom we
didn't [__] in the bathroom but we did
go in the bathroom together because I
had like an outfit that
needed a second pair of hands let's say
that so uh so yeah we both went in there
and we're considered kind of Staff
because we do all their so they don't
care if we use the employee bathroom
yeah we do all their they don't care if
we both go in there together we do all
their online promotion and the owner big
Tom was a good buddy of mine he buddy of
ours for [__] 20 years 15 [__]
years
now so like I'm also kind of like
security too I could bounce a
[__] from there if necessary
yeah if necessary I do I can do it
anything there but yeah I mean we did go
in there together last time but I mean
Tom just peed and then I just peed
because I was just kind of like look I
have to go to the bathroom and in a
hurry and I can't fix this so he's like
well I kind of have to P to let's just
go in there yeah you know what I mean so
we just did that Carrie's asking us to
go she didn't she hasn't I haven't seen
her in a while oh I I get I know [__]
um Grand's Hammer's still in there
Carrie is Jennifer jeffy's little sister
from TR yeah so granda's would know her
yeah Grand's probably know he knows who
Jenny DJ's down here sometimes yeah
car's here car's a go chick I'll show
you
Carrie is Granda still in there I don't
know I haven't seen him in a lot in a
while but yeah she was asking us to come
out because they were coming her and
Jack were coming yeah I guess Jack is
coming but I haven't seen her in a while
she's lost a lot of weight yeah she she
looks great yeah like last time I saw
her at momento Mory
not the last one but I think before that
so a couple months ago and she looked
[__] fantastic yeah that's car she
looked fantastic yeah she so
skinny Danny says club sex could be your
new video on 13 cams on many yeah we've
thought about it it's just like I never
I never take my phone in the club
because I just don't think about it I
usually just leave it in the trunk cuz I
don't ever look at it I'm too busy like
dancing and drinking and whatnot but
that's Carrie yeah the new skinny
Carrie yeah like I said I saw her
momento a couple months ago and she
looked [__] fantastic
yeah she's lost at least 100 pounds at
least if not more first time first time
I saw Carrie Carrie was probably about
seven or eight yeah in the front seat of
[__] Jenny Jeffrey's car [__]
bouncing up and down going hey how are
you doing so how you doing how you doing
Kitty pie I was I was in high school at
that time yeah yeah she was like a
little kid she was like a little kid
when I first but she lives down here now
and she comes out all like I said she
DJs at um man she used to DJ at
mannequin yeah she's
DJ Spooky Puffs I think it's her DJ name
that's a good [__]
outfit yeah she's she's cool I like her
yeah her sister had the Hops for me so
much [__] was she the one that had
the shrine she had a shrine built to me
in high
school I love that
story and you never really went out with
her did you no she's a friend of mine
though yeah you were friends with her
but you I liked her yeah but I I didn't
want to go out with cuz I didn't she try
to like uh yeah
yeah yeah I heard that story yeah cuz I
make him tell me all the all the juicy
details of all the [__] to happen
because he's got lots of good stories I
don't have that many good stories but
you have a lot of good ones
yeah okay I'm going to get I'm going to
pull up a old picture
of this is this is Jen now that's Jenny
now now that's how she looks now she's
my
age all right I'll show you the way Jen
looked in high school She's Got High
School pictures up here says try to what
oh you know yeah she that was her in
high school jump on that D yeah that's
what Sheed yeah she was cute she was
cute he told me that he told me the
whole story she was cute I was just kind
of scared of her she was uh she was a
little aggressive not like not like
super aggressive but you know she was
basically like hey let's do she fly
around yeah yeah yeah you know there she
is that's her the blonde yeah so ' 80s
that that's 80s as [__] that's how she
looked back I love the Clockwork Orange
like shirt there though yeah and then
the other one [__] she was cute too
the
[__] they're still like best friends
that's awesome though yeah they're still
like best friends yeah they went to prom
together that's awesome yeah although
they married dudes but you know they're
not they're not lesbians but they were
just like best friends they were [__]
totally
Inseparable well see but see that's the
thing I kind of feel like a lot of um
high school girls are like that yeah
like I said we have like women have
closer friendships girls have closer
friendships and dudes do and I think and
I think it's really weird the way like
people are be like oh those two girls
they hang out all together they're
lesbians I'm like nah not usually
they're just hanging out together
they're best friends you know what I
mean and it's not as weird I feel like
it's not as weird yeah that other
chick's name was Julie Jones Julie Jones
that was it I actually wanted to go out
with her but [__] Steve is like my
friend said no don't do it man Jenny
will go [__] crazy it it'll break him
up I was like yeah probably right oh
because the other one was so the best
friend was yeah so well I think that was
really nice go with Julie though in high
school that you had the presence of mind
I didn't well no ST Steve did he says
you better not but he's like yeah
because those two are best friends if
you go out cuz she's in love with you
you want to go out with the other one
and that and because that absolutely
would have happened so I was like yeah
you're right they would have become like
mortal enemies yeah cuz that's what
happened between Girls and High School
man you would like some dude you didn't
you didn't tread there if you're best
friend was after a dude yeah even if you
wanted that dude too you just you didn't
go there you didn't go there because the
friendship with the girl was more
valuable I would have went after Julie
in a [__] heartbeat yeah she was
little and cute and didn't say anything
she was just like real [__] she would
just laugh or go but she was smart real
smart but but she was so shy she didn't
say anything so she was like real
mysterious you know what I'm talking
about just like I want to get down the
bottom of this [__] I want to get down
to the bottom yeah I want to get down
the bottom
that's she was just real cute and quiet
and [__] like a little ghost you
know yeah and would just giggle see
there vanish if you're cute and you have
like that Mystique mhm where you're not
kind of like out yeah I I mean you know
when people meet you you might actually
be an [__] or I later on told her
that yeah yeah I was like you know
[__] I would have gone out with you
in a heartbeat [__] but I was so SC I
didn't want to break you guys up she was
like really I was like I had no idea and
I was like yeah isn't it weird like I
found out years later yeah that like
certain dudes had like had a crush on me
in school and it's like I didn't even
know mhm that just goes to show how
lowkey they were yeah because it's like
I Bo I didn't notice yeah Julie thought
that I was you say something Julie kind
of thought that I was out of her League
cuz I was messing around with Mary Lynn
and the other girls and [__] like that
but no we used to see her at Denny's all
the time I was when all the gos are
hanging out at Denny's we were all in
high school together goth was the go
kind of all hung out at Denny well
because that was one of the only places
in shitty small towns that were open all
night so it's like a lot of times after
you went to a show or after you went to
a club everybody would go there like to
get omelets or whatever Denny's was our
version of Starbucks yeah that's where
you went and got coffee yeah you went
there and got bre like pancakes or
whatever the [__] well you couldn't
afford all that all the time though you
just get some every now and then if you
got like You' have to go up to the
counter I remember going to Denny's
after going to shows at vage or
something like that like in Orlando like
sometimes we go to punk shows and so
like we'd be in there and some of us
would have like head injuries because of
being in the mosh pit and stuff so you
have like blood trickling down your head
and be like yeah just can I get some
piig yeah you know what I mean the
waitresses were just like so [__]
Blas about it because it's like it you
know it happened all the time they're
just like you guys all right yeah we're
fine thank you yeah he said Mur is
talking about yeah I get good deals
because we're [__] Army Bros yeah
we're VA Army Bros I know I know the
deal I know the deal I'm almost I'm G
[__] break you off here soon bro
don't
worry Tom's got Tom's got some money
coming although like I said I'm going
break you off some we we need to get
some stuff we need a new car we need a
new bed cuz we broke it yeah cuz we
broke it yeah so we need another one we
might want to get that sex doll make
videos with some more more
[__] got torso thing so you could do
some solo [__] I like that but it's just
like I don't know it's kind of weird but
I mean it is a lot cheaper I get you a
Fooda one get you [__] [__] [__]
sex doll maybe we should yeah well you
know what would probably be you know
what would probably be the most cost
efficient option yeah because look that
those realistic sex dolls are not cheap
I mean they're very expensive they're
pushing a grand for a good one yeah
they're like
$900 so it's just kind of like if you
want to get one if we want to get one to
make videos with it would probably be
good if we could have one that had
options what you could do is you could
we could is all I'm saying you could get
one of the female ones and [__] and
do they have like aftermarket kits that
you could put like a dick on it if you
want there's [__] like that or you can
put or you could put different heads on
strap on different heads well that would
work also and then you can also get
different bodies they have a [__]
basically a Fooda body like some of
anime yeah but that that which is Fe
dick girl all right yeah but [__]
thing is is about those things are
huge cuz Fooda Fooda animation is
outside [__] human Realms of [__]
normal for [__] I love I love Fooda
animation that [__] like [__] you'd be
like having a fire extinguisher those
are so awesome yeah I love those but
yeah they're they're not super realistic
most of them are not but I like them I
want to get the elf head I like the
monster ones too like I like the
werewolves and [__] like that I like
yeah all the
animation I didn't think I would really
like animated porn but actually I like
it better than actual people porn well
it's cuz more things are possible and
it's and and it's vegan no no no one and
you know yeah
and you know that that person like it's
not a person so it's like you don't have
to worry about is that person really
into this or you know what I mean so
yeah so I I can enjoy it with a clearer
cont the proportions of all the people
are far outside human Norms it's like
superheroes and [__] yeah yeah so you
can do a lot more with it which it's
creative I like that yeah and
everything's idealized people can't be
that good-looking not real life yeah
like I said we we we used to watch like
the long like when we were doing streams
and stuff yeah we'd have like six hours
we would like have like a six hour
compilation of like monster animated
porn yeah like elves getting [__] by
werewolves and [__] like that it was all
[__] from World of Warcraft yeah they're
super fun they're super fun yeah and
[__] I'd be on Viagra and we'd be on
all kinds of [__] [__] doing video
waiting for customers to come in yeah
then we like man nobody's coming in here
[__] got boring after a while it does
get boring like when people don't come
in there that's why we haven't done it
we have regulars asking us where we
where are we yeah I get emails sometimes
from people being like hey where have
you been we'll jump back in we'll do
some I mean yeah I like making videos
more cuz then you can just you have more
control with video Oracle said a girl's
first best friendship is a kind of First
Love yeah yeah it is it is I was
thinking about going out with
Julie I was like Steve man
[__] I can go there and get that cuz
she was I'm gonna go giving me all the
singles you know and that she was big
into Ministry she was goth girl you know
Ministry she loaned me a Ministry tape
oh yeah that's a plus she loan me I was
listening to it in the car she's super
cool especially like back then that's
super cool yeah let me a Ministry tape
cuz there weren't that many people that
would do that back she had the [__]
huge hair the huge Robert Smith hair and
[__] we all kind of had big hair back
then and I'm like and he's he goes he
goes dude if you do that you're gonna
have to [__] marry her basically
because [__] Jen's going to go
[__] crazy and those two are not
going to be able to hang out again
you're going to [__] that up that whole
friendship yeah yeah and I was like you
probably would have yeah and I was like
yeah you're
right basically I don't remember exactly
the the the wording we didn't have the
term hitting and quit but he that's what
he meant he says you can't hit and quit
that yeah because then you're [__] it
[__] both of them up she you're going
to have to marry that
basically you know what he meant was
you're going have to go steady with her
for a long time right and [__] you
know those days that was oh that was a
huge commit yeah see here's the problem
this is something that women don't
understand Oh's I'm going tell y'all
let's hear what women don't understand
this should be good dudes get a [__]
up reputation for hitting and quitting
and [__] being [__] dogs and [__]
[__] when they're young and they oh
these guys I can't trust I hate them you
don't understand the problems that young
guys are going
through when you're a young
dude you may have the look you might be
interesting okay you don't have any
money though and you don't have a career
but you might be [__] interesting
enough to attract these girls but you
know in your heart when you're young
like that when you're a guy you can't
keep them so you can't offer anything to
these women except a brief en encounter
you don't make any
money so you can't commit you can't
compete with the older guys so all you
can do in your 20s for most of it is hit
and
quit cuz if you stay with her long
enough she's going to realize how
limited you are and what you're limited
your resources are so you got to get the
[__] out of there while the glamour is
high because after a couple months she's
going to think you're a [__] loser
when she finds out how little money you
make and how un undependable you are and
how you can't get a job that you can't
hold a job for long because you're just
too [__] young and you know the dudes
in their 30s are making money hand over
fist a lot of those girls in their
[__] early 20s need to be dudes of
their 30s you don't you can't offer
anything to a woman in your 20s you got
to be a hoe that's all you can
do and women can't grasp that they just
come down to the guy but a guy has to
defend his his
image so all you can do is hit and
quit before they find out what a fraud
you
are now you understand you can't offer
them anything no I mean you can't take
care of them understood that before yeah
you can't do anything for them women
understand that honey it's it's okay
we're not that dumb yeah we're not dumb
so all you can do is be sex machine
dudes are really not that hard to figure
out I don't know why you think they're
so mysterious they're well no they get M
get all bitter they're really not
they're getting bitter over what what
dudes do in their [__] team well I
don't know about that I think I think
women get when all that [__] starts I
think women get bitter about what dudes
just do in general like no matter what
age they are well the bad behavior that
dudes do like I I gota I gotta admit I
was in some ways you it was bad behavior
I was kind of forced into it up until my
30s
really you're just not stable enough
well yeah and like I said I think
everybody when they're young yeah I
wouldn't really advise anybody to make
any like kind of big commitments or
anything like that when you're you're
you're really not done developing yet
like I said I don't really feel like I
was an adult until I was probably like
38 you know yeah so take take of that
what you will I mean yeah I had bought a
house before that I had got married
before that I had done this and that and
I did adult [__] and I did it
successfully I had jobs and whatnot but
I didn't really feel like a grown whole
person until I was almost 40 I listen to
Tammy how many girls out there were
looking for dudes with
money when you're [__] broke when
you're a young guy and you're broke you
can't offer anything to these women that
another dude can't beat you in you're
you're the dudes in their late 20s and
their 30s are going to beat you uh
[__] at every
turn so you're you're you've only made
it the Pretty Boy way it then that
doesn't have any staying power you're
not Dependable you're not reliable you
can't reliably put food on a table or
pay rent real well you know everything
is temporary when you're that
young Karen says my hubby and I broke
the bed but it didn't stop us
ha well it didn't stop us either we just
move we just moved to the floor just
notice that they're bre that or to the
living room like I said we just noticed
that it's like wow this bed's really
soft in this area looking the
supporten and then it was broken like oh
we're breaking a bed whoops yeah so uh
yeah we need to get another one well
like I said we've had that one for a
while and it it was in the guest room
for a long time I don't even know how
old it was before we got it for the
guest room half hour I think we got it
used
um let's see all about the D says murder
Hornet H yeah I don't know yeah James
says yeah I wasn't a real adult till
like 35 as well yeah I kind of feel like
maybe I mean if people are younger than
that that might be like a weird thing to
say but I didn't feel like an adult
person and like I said I had jobs I had
a car I had a house I had a mortgage uh
I was married for 14 years didn't have
any kids but you know I never wanted
them but I didn't really feel like an
adult until after I got divorced and
moved to an apartment on my own and like
started doing [__] like that I didn't
have any [__] money but yeah but that
was the first time that I felt like a
grown ass person yeah when you're when
you're a guy in your 20s late teens and
your 20s you're you're constantly under
the
shadow of inadequacy you feel very
inadequate because you see the guys that
are older than you are doing much better
than
you you know what I mean they have a lot
more to offer
you know so you're with this 21 year old
girl and you go yeah all I need is a
yeah you know any minute a 30-y old's
going to come by and [__] snag this
you know one of these big mouth bass in
the pond will come and just boom get it
you know what I mean I mean you know you
know you don't really have what and the
girls seem to know too that you ain't
[__] I
mean I guess it depends on the girl and
I and I think that a lot of dudes have
that impression because of the types of
girls that they're going after maybe
yeah um you know other types of girls
would not be like that cuz I wouldn't
have been like that that never really in
my early concerned that in my early to
mid
20s women in their early to mid 20s were
kind of indifferent towards you they'll
take you or leave you but they kind of
had an accurate view like yeah you look
good and everything but you're not
Dependable you you can't really put food
on the table you're not going to help me
pay rent that's the way they they see
you the ones that did see you as a huge
move up were teenage girls like [__]
high school [__] like last year of
high school or right out of high school
they thought you were great but you
couldn't date them your friends would
make fun of you you know what I mean cuz
they were too young yeah they would be
legal in the states that you were in but
your friends would be like she you what
are you going to do take her to the club
she can't even drink yeah you know
so you'd be like 24 and she's like
[__] 18 but you can't do anything
with her 17 you can't do anything with
her you can't take her anywhere friends
would laugh at you yeah I mean although
there were some girls that were in there
were girls that were in um
manre which is the goth club in Boston I
was hanging out at that time who were
17 all right and nobody knew they were
17 and they were strippers at 17 which
was illegal you could get away with a
lot more back then but they weren't
didn't care as much yeah well that was
why you could get away with a lot more
back then yeah were 17 they were
stripping yeah and they were in [__]
because they look so good they just got
in they're not going to say you no you
can't come in okay and they were G yeah
but they were high school
dropouts yeah Tammy say and Tom acting
like we're going with older men for the
money yeah it's just kind of like that's
the thing not just the money well like I
said it depends on one the type of girl
that they're going after which like I
said if they're going after like super
young super hot ones like maybe some of
them are like that but like I said not
everybody's the same I wasn't like that
I didn't really give a [__] about
people's money or really what they
looked like I just kind of liked their
Vibe I just kind of like them as a
person a young guy with a [__] ton of
money can clean up because women know he
has a [__] ton of M money he might be a
celebrity but these young girls were not
going after the other guys because of
the money they had money that was one
factor dudes are do not cannot bring to
the table the qualities a woman wants
until they're about
30 that's when they have some gravitas
they have some stability well they have
some maturity they have some maturity so
the guys in his 20 just does not have
the personal qualities that yeah I don't
even I don't even think it's just money
I just think it's no 20-year-old dudes
are are yeah idiots yeah but if you are
in your 20s and you have a [__] ton of
money no you can hook up yeah now are
any of them going to hang around long
term probably not uh no May well maybe
I'm not going to say that [__]
Leonardo decaprio at 25 was [__]
cleaning up what are you talking about
he's not going right but the thing about
him he Super Famous and he might have
been a cool dude and he was yeah he
seems to be very cool he seems to be
very and that is a big factor like I
said Being a woman I'm not speaking for
all women obviously but it's just kind
of like if you're just like a cool dude
and you have like a lot like a good
personality and stuff that actually does
go a long way yeah it helps if you're
rich and famous sure that helps
everybody see more DiCaprio's money I'll
ask around I'll ask but if you're rich
and famous and you're a dick yeah you
know you're going to get yeah you'll get
some women to hang around for a little
while but they're going to [__] off
eventually because they can't stand your
ass DiCaprio does not come off as a dick
he seems to be cool he doesn't I don't I
and I haven't heard anything bad about
him but I don't really follow that so I
don't kind of think DiCaprio might be a
guy kind of like Kurt Russell I think I
mean I like Kurt I think DiCaprio is
married to someone much younger but I
don't think anybody really like freaked
out about it because he didn't make a
big deal about it you know what I mean
man gonna get what he can get they like
young women that are beautiful he can
take care of her and he and if he dies
she's getting all his [__] well like I
said [__] I kind of feel like some
like some older dudes that have like a
lot of money and stuff like they'll be
like they get a much
younger or girlfriend or whatever and
they'll sport her around everywh like
look what I got blah blah blah so I kind
of feel like DiCaprio got a much younger
wife but he didn't do that like he
didn't make a huge deal about it
Leonardo [__] so I think people
were cooler about it because they're
like well he wasn't
like acting like it was like he was just
trying to be like hey look what I got
that was normal for him because they
were always like that yeah that was
normal for him but no I [__] DiCaprio
knows here's another thing a lot of
older women they look at these older
guys that they would want to date and
they're with young women they're going
to get butt hurt they're GNA say oh well
he's not secure with himself no DiCaprio
is very secure with himself okay he's
also
very The Sensation that an older guy
gets by taking care of a younger
beautiful woman is kind of the Sensation
that a woman gets when she's taking care
of like a baby like a cute baby he can
take care of her he can make sure she's
totally satisfied money and he's
treating her like a princess and that
makes him feel good and I'm sure she
loves him and I it does not [__] I
guarantee you DiCaprio can throw down in
the bedroom and that woman loves him
probably okay he's not a disappointment
okay like I said I've never really heard
anything bad about maybe it's out there
like I said I don't follow it so I
wouldn't really know but I've never
heard anything like egregious he can fly
her all around the world in private jets
and they can they have all he I have a
feeling he's very cool he seems cool
yeah he's probably very cool so I you I
don't know like I said if anybody knows
anything that like some [__] up [__]
because the thing about it like even
some like actors and stuff that seem
cool and then you find out oh he raped
all these women and [__] like that oh
suddenly not so cool anymore but I never
I've never heard anything bad about he's
got those young girls floating on air
okay they [__] love it and he
probably feels like a king you know
which is that that that's good to him he
can but he seems to keep it lowkey which
I think a lot of people respect more and
he cuz look if you're going to like like
I said if you're going to date somebody
that's young enough to be your daughter
I don't think people are averse to that
necessarily but I think 30 is young
enough to be my daughter well yeah but
grown woman I think people are averse to
you just like going out and being like
hey look at this young like you know
what I mean just like showing her off
like she's an object DiCaprio not not
corny right so I think that's why he
[__] just corny every day Normie
[__] he's going to be corny and
[__] with it here wear the see-through
dress you 25-year-old girlfriend and I'm
like a 55y old man he yeah I think the
average guy is going to be corny and
then everyone's gonna be like to him him
it's just normal tacky to him it's just
normal it's tacky well it's the same
thing they kind of did that [__] to
Jason STM because he's got a young wife
too and [__] women were saying that
ugly old [__] I asked Jenny says
you think Jason St is he a good-looking
guy and she goes yeah he's Jason St is
not ugly he don't look ugly to me I
think he looks all right right and it
was just he's not really my type he's a
r he's a Ruffian he's a rough guy if he
like if I met him like if he was nobody
and I met him in a bar and he was like
super cool and funny' be I'd hit that
yeah yeah I [__] I understand no
problem at all cuz he's he he he comes
off as just a cool kind of he's
interesting and and he has a certain
amount of strength to him you know what
I mean and he look he could handle his
business and he's in good shape um he
looks good bald uh I like his accent and
uh he he's funny he comes across
intelligent too yeah like he he's
playing the [__] dumb he's
charismatic yeah he's got he's
charismatic and I like him in his
gangster roles and [__] and I like him
so like I said it would it doesn't
really if he's if someone is charismatic
it doesn't really matter to me like what
they look like really so he's with this
23 year old or something you know what I
mean but that's not weird that's not I
don't think that's weird I don't think
that's weird because who's she she
probably doesn't really come from much
and he's got her walking on clouds and
uh she's they're having fun which that's
fine they're having fun and [__] if
he gets old he dies she gets all his
[__] he knows it he's probably says
don't worry I'll take care of you if I
die you have everything and you and your
new man will
go do it in the accent do it in the
accent I can't do it accent I know you
can't that's
why if I die baby you go ahead I can't
do it brsh you [__]
[__] that's what he would say not really
no no I'm just saying you know if I die
you're GNA have everything I'll take
care of you Tom asked me these questions
like it's like do you think this dude is
ugly or better yeah I was like well um
and out of the blue and she gets
confused why I'm asking it I was like I
I don't know I don't know
him that's what I always say well I was
just going I don't know him so I don't
can't tell you the physical aspects I
wasn't asking about the overall like I
said it's not I there's a physical score
and is an overall school right but it's
just kind of like here's the thing we're
a lot more complicated yeah dudes find
it very easy to like look at a chick and
be like oh that's a eight or that's a
like I can't do that like I said I look
at a just a physical person like a
celebrity or something I don't know that
person right um so I'm just kind of
like I there I can't yeah it's too
reductive I can't I can't bring it down
to like a number score because I don't
know that person if I knew that person
and they were an a douche yeah then
their score would drop drastically no
matter what they look like yeah but if
they were super cool then their score
would go way up yeah but I don't know
them so I can't tell you Karen says when
she said I love taking care of my man
what you I love taking care of my man
and he takes care of me yeah and that's
what's and she says she's 64 she's 64
okay well that's that's what that's what
those old guys are doing yeah um they
got money all right and those girls
volunteered all right and [__] IDE
and those dud are famous all right and
they're F and they look good and they're
older guys and they have a lot to offer
a young woman uh just in in a lot of
different ways they both seem
intelligent they're wise they got a lot
of [__] money they probably a lot of
fun I think both of those guys are very
fun well they've probably learned some
[__] which is good cuz like I said dudes
in their 20s they they don't really know
much of anything and then these young
women are offering them Beauty
and good sex and [__] uh fun and uh
she's doing her Duty probably had give
him some children probably if she if he
wants it and she's taken care of she's
got a retirement package and everything
so that's and and thing is is all the
damn status that he has you know what I
mean that that's all goes on to her you
know what I mean the [__] the wife of
Jason ston the wife of Leonardo DiCaprio
got Leonardo DiCaprio's babe
Le Leonardo DiCaprio Jr okay so yeah so
what what more could a young woman ask
for that is that is going to have some
cache in in many circles yeah so you
know like I said it's not really
something but like I said ideally just
for us normal
people ideally you need to find somebody
you Vibe with and you can take care of
each other yeah I think that is kind of
the best situation right yeah you would
agree with that would you not yeah yeah
yeah well it's like symbiosis yeah yeah
it's a symbiotic situation you know
what's hilarious I posted a picture of
me and you from mannequins from last
Friday yeah and somebody on there
commented couple goals yeah yeah that
girl said the couple goals is what
couples are
wishing well we're old and we still do
pretty good I do kind of feel it and you
kind of said [__] pushing 60 kind of
said this before yeah and a lot and some
of our friends have said this too A lot
of people are kind of I don't know if I
want to say jealous but like
envious I don't know if you call it that
maybe I don't know I kind of got that
impr I don't think in a negative way no
not in yeah that's why I didn't want to
say jealous because that has a negative
connotation I want say they're
respectful
yeah CU a lot of people do kind of
like I don't know if I want to say they
ask us about it
but it is kind of something that comes
up a
lot but I don't know I don't think we're
that unusual are we yeah oh are we yeah
I went back to Mississippi and saw
everybody down there from that town that
[__] I was partially kind of grew up
in a little bit and uh looked at all the
dudes that were my age and with their
wives I was oh okay
yeah we don't we don't look like a lot
of 50y old
couples or 50 couple year olds yeah
those dudes are 100 pound heavier than
me
yeah easily 60 to 100 lounds heavier
than me and bad clothes and [__] up
hair and
uh uh the wives are look
miserable they're just putting up with
[__] trying to get with this
[__] it's just a Daily Grind and
no it's like I'm just too tired to
divorce them yeah all we're in our 50s
we have a [__] life we have a life
that [__] we're living a life that
people are 20s wish they could look
we're like rock stars basically I mean
not that cool cuz we don't have all have
more money they have a lot more money
but we can do without needing money or
fame we just have fun without money yeah
yeah that's kind of the secret we just
have good local connections yeah and
like I said I think one of the main
things is
that when you get together with somebody
you have
to like that person as a person you know
what I mean it's like if you are just
into a because like oh they have a hot
bot or whatever for other reasons yeah
that might last for a while but it's not
going to last that long you have to like
that person you have to want to hang out
with that person because you're going to
be hanging out with that person and
doing boring [__] with that person for
years and years and years so you have to
find somebody that you're cool with
doing that with
yeah okay well here's my
comment
I've been with some women that were
[__] outstanding I I sometimes I was
just physically punching above my weight
probably got ones that I probably
shouldn't able to get all right
um yeah you hit that man it's [__] it
blows your mind maybe once or twice then
quickly it wears off if that girl
[__]
sucks it does you seen me do it before
we were going out yeah they but the
thing is as a man as a man you know it's
coming you know she sucks you're going
to hit it anyway you're just like yeah
I'm just going to hit it I'm going to
hit that [__] anyway then after a while
you're like I'm so sick of this [__] I'm
sick of this dick just really not enough
and a lot of women who look good
sometimes lean on that ability well you
can Coast on it for a long time Co on it
for a long [__] time but they got to
jump from man to man because they're
only good for a couple weeks before like
I can't [__] stand this [__] more
terrible [__] personality and just
dumb as [__] her her priorities are [__]
and you know just she's fake as [__] you
know what I mean she's kind of a
sociopath or real you know what do you
call it or something there could be real
narcissistic and she thinks she's more
than what she
is then you see that [__] [__] five
years later and she's [__] 20 pounds
heavier and she's just not that same
person anymore you're like [__] that Jak
So Physical Beauty and and physical
beauty is only one factor everybody has
to maintain everybody should be
physically attractive for their age age
affects your physical attractiveness but
[__] you should be physically
attrative but everybody can do stuff
like whatever age yeah because
everything's life is B is a battle it's
a constant Warfare fighting and your
main enemy is
time
time when I was young I used to think
time would last forever that it was
wasn't precious timebody time is [__]
precious every felt that you got to
every day you got to do something that
helps you move
up
but yeah and you can't do it and it's
hard me and Jenny physically trained
today she [__] trained hard in the
gym and now she's cheating too she's
she's [__] she's on gear but we're
both on gear we're old we you can take
gear you should take gear when you're
old I mean anything that's going to like
prolong the [__] yeah because you don't
have androgenic signaling and anabolic
signaling and stuff because your your
hormones are not being produced so you
got to put something in there hormone
replacement yeah cuz I've been through
menopause right you know that's how
[__] and I went through and androgena
which is male menopause that happens
around 50 normally you start getting fat
weak [__] like that no I start injecting
testosterone which bucks you back
up and your performance in all fuckingg
all [__] levels goes way up well plus
you got a lot you let I'm embarrassed
how many times I [__] want to hit
this a
day like it is egregious yeah I try to
keep it to
myself fuing like try to hit but [__]
well it would be let me go to the
restroom it I I feel annoying you know
what I mean fuing well how many times a
day are we talking about I I could
probably go two three times a day that's
all right
okay why didn't you tell me
okay why didn't you tell
me I I'd be down for that I mean you
know but yeah so well and like I said I
did notice we kind of had after he went
on um you know testosterone all the
steroids and stuff because for the first
few years of our relationship it was
just kind of
like I felt like he was always kind of
like in a bad place and I knew his past
and I knew where he had come from and
you know he had some bad [__] happen to
him back in the
day um so I kind of knew that so I gave
him a lot of leeway but but after a time
I was just kind of like man he's just
seems like he's always like depressed or
he's always bummed out or he doesn't
really have a lot of energy or whatever
and finally he was just kind of like you
know maybe it's low test and he went to
the clinic and honestly like as soon as
he went on that it was like a huge huge
difference a huge difference and he was
even talking like at my stepdad's
funeral last weekend cuz both of my
brothers were there who are younger than
me like one of them is four years
younger one of of them is 14 years
younger yeah he was born in
1986 so he's still in his 30s but my
other brother is only you know he's in
his late 40s and Tom was like trying to
get them like at least my older brother
uh to go on test and I was just kind of
like and I had been talking to him about
that before at another funeral that me
and him went to which was my
grandmother's funeral and I was just
kind of like yeah it really made a
massive massive difference not just in
the sex drive which is nice but just in
mood energy um you know he seemed a lot
more upbeat cuz prior to that he was
just kind of like man I'm going to die
soon I'm going to do I'm just like dude
you're like 50 calm down you know what I
mean it was just you're young still but
he was just getting to a point where
it's like yeah I'm just I'm just going
down the decline you know and it's not
like that anymore it's not like that
anymore so I would advise like dudes
that are now you've said that yeah had
you known what you know now you would
have gone on it a lot earlier I would
have gone on at 35 I got to pee now too
okay knowing what I've known now would
have gone on around
35 that would have uh saved me some
declin because your 40s start to get a
little rough you're not quite who you
really should
be normal routines normal diets that
you're used to your body doesn't respond
the same way it's cuz you're just you're
just not producing the testosterone that
you did
so really you should be replacing your
own body's natural production of
testosterone with exogenous testosterone
that comes out of a
bottle
now some people have problems with
needles I had problem with it until I
shot some once I shot some a week later
I was like yeah I want more of that
[__] it immediately [__] makes a
difference
so it's cheapest ways to go black market
there's a lot of ways to do it
steroidify.com is one of the places that
[__] I can go it's a Chinese
International
Brokers they can help you out they'll
take zel payments in crypto or bit which
is like
Bitcoin but if you're too bashful and
you're very security
minded you can just look up a
local HRT hormone replacement therapy
clinic or testosterone clinic near me
you just search sech it on Google and
something will come up you go there
that's how I just started you go there
they're going to do some blood tests on
you they're going to look at your your
[__] test
level it's probably going to be low if
you're going it's
low definitely lower than Mine mine's
like three times that of a human but
it's going to be
low so then they'll uh usually they're
for about 200 bucks a month they'll hook
you up with uh some 200
milligram [__] testosterone cypionate
and maybe some like some HCG or clo
pills and you'll do that for a couple
months you'll see big
improvements that's weak sauce to me now
uh and way too
expensive I can for 200 bucks a month I
can just [__] get loaded on some of
the [__] best [__] ever but if I
wanted to keep just 200 milligrams of
[__] a
week no I can get that for 60 bucks a
month through the gray
market now when you go black
market don't think this is that these
drugs are being made in somebody's
basement somewhere this is
over-the-counter [__] from
major pharmaceutical manufacturers you
know it's just that it would be over
the-counter in another country in this
country it's not over the counter you
need a prescription for it but there are
ways to get it to you here all right
steroidify is pretty good and if they
lose a shipment if it gets nabbed
they'll just send you another
one and then it'll mail it right to you
the border is
open it's just the way this the system
works yeah you just got to find a work
find way yeah you can get anything here
pretty much yeah so if you've never done
it you might want to go through a clinic
first we'll just so you get familiarity
with I with it what it feels
like [__] feels like and what the dosage
is like and you get up habits so you
know what your blood work looks like
then once you get through that you
realize where you are you're like N I
can take twice that three times that you
matter of fact let's take steroids on
top of that now somebody say well
steroids that's that's oh that's too
harsh
no testosterone cypionate is harder on
you than those
steroids there's a there's a an overdose
point and once you start pushing 600
milligrams 700 milligrams a week of
testosterone the side effects are it's a
lot of load on you it's called
androgenic load better to drop that [__]
down to about 200 or 300 milligrams of
testosterone and put another 300 or 400
milligrams of some kind of steroid on
top of that it'll go a lot smoothly
because there's a lot less side effects
with test with steroids that's what
they're for steroids is testosterone
with the with the androgenic side
effects do that's that's the the
androgenic side effects is what make
male secondary sex characteristics like
hair growth and [__] deepening of
voice they have that lessened off of the
testosterone so you can give it to women
and children and you can give a lot of
it to a woman or a child without turning
them into a man you give it to a man
it's like giving him a bunch of
testosterone without the side effects
yeah so people think that [__]
steroids are some kind of like
underground weird chemical bad [__] no
you know what the [__] it's it's just
testosterone with the [__] male
characteristics taken off of it that's
all it is and it has a much higher
overdose point you can take a [__] ton
of that a lot I don't I've never taken
any more than a th milligrams of
anything combined a week yeah Danny said
that stuff changed your voice hard as
[__] I know it did I know it does but
that's about was taking quite a bit
though and it took a long yeah and it
wasn't the stuff that I'm on now yeah
um it was winra that did that yeah
Winstrol did that yeah and she's still
within the female range though there are
female I was kind of bothered at first
but I don't really mind it anymore to be
honest and I didn't really get any other
side effects every woman that has a good
bill very minor here's the thing every
woman that has a good build who's been
in the gym has a voice like
that I think it's kind of much worse
much if I do say so myself yeah once a
woman is kind of [__] jacked and [__]
and she's [__] ripped she's has kind
of a Kim K's kind of voice that's a
little rougher even if she wasn't on
gear because she because she's working
out when she's young like that she's
going to be producing testosterone women
make
it um yeah we do but you know if she's
not real physical she's going to have a
little squeaky voice and like I said I
always kind of felt i' never had this
tested obviously but just
from the way that I assumed because of
the way that I was I always assumed that
I had slightly higher testosterone than
other women not because I mean I was
still attracted to dudes mostly although
I would consider myself by but I was
always into like more dude [__] yeah I
was into FEI [__] too but not as much I
didn't really like FEI [__] I like kind
of like I like horror movies and like I
like man [__] kind of I'm not really
into cars or anything like that J J's
kind of a tomboy a little bit a little
bit Yeah so not like some not like some
chicks are I'm not I didn't go that far
cuz I still liked some FEI [__] like I I
still liked makeup and all that kind of
crap I still like like women stuff but I
I liked a lot of dude stuff too I was
kind of in the middle you know yeah but
she's nothing compared to some of the
female bodybuilders that I've talked to
you know like
Chelsea Chelsea's 51 and Way's [__]
two 220 lbs and she's [__] pure
muscle I still think she's cute I I'd
hit to me I still recognize her as a
woman but you hear a voice that sounds
like a guy similar to mine I think she's
I think she's beautiful though she's
cute um especially when she's not real
pumped up when she's pumped up and she's
doing a show yeah she's [__] ripped
you know what I mean she looks like a
female Arnold Schwarzenegger but when
she's just walking around you know and
when she's in the offseason she just
looks like a put together
cute chick you know she gets guys she's
got boyfriends they all they're all
worked they they they're all jacked too
though so women who are jacked like
that they're for a different audience
yeah they're not for you nonworking out
[__] they they're they're
because there are those people in there
because inevitably every time they post
something on Tik Tok or whatever there's
going to be like a certain percentage of
the comments that are going to be like
looks like a man looks like a man a man
you put her next to her boyfriend no she
does not look like a man she looks like
a woman she does not look like a woman
you put you next to her yeah she like a
man next to you that's why they're mad
that's why they're but you but you look
like a woman next to her boyfriend
okay cuz why would you even comment that
it's just like you're just inviting
everybody knows that you don't look as
good as that yeah she's way too muscular
the dude mother [__] fat as a
[__] okay that's what I it's
like I I don't get it I don't get it
yeah like look if you if you see a video
of somebody and you're just like a that
person looks [__] up or whatever like
how about this how about just go to the
next video and just don't comment don't
comment I don't I like here's the thing
I don't know who it was that told you
that your opinion meant [__] all to
anybody in the world but that person was
mistaken although look that person was
kind of changed
recently most of the comments the
negative comments on the female [__]
Fitness checks that are [__] shredded
aren't coming from America anymore most
of it's from India oh yeah most of it's
from India and those are some little
skinny jean little skinny [__]
with the little Indian skinny guy jeans
and [__] you know although they do have
some someone's intimidating they're
getting yeah they're like oh she look
like a Oh that girl could kick my ass
yeah that girl could kick your ass she
probably could she could kick her ass
she could dude you weigh 125 she could
kick most dude's asses I feel and that's
badass I love that now not to [__]
and so Indian bodybuilders they got some
[__] big dudes in India but they're
bodybuilders and they're on gear but
your average Dude down there he's small
all
right they don't wa they don't have the
diet lot they're almost vegan a lot of
those guys you they just can't build
muscle um let me see hold
on Victor said I've been on 200 uh
milligrams of test and my voice never
Chang changed but I had my labs drawn
two weeks ago my Tesla was 950 oh that's
good yeah that is good uh Danny says why
does that stuff change the sound of your
someone's voice just wonder it only
change well it changed my voice because
I'm way outside human Norms but your
voice isn't sound that different to me h
no it's a lot more gra my voice sounds
like a lot different I could sound I
didn't really I didn't notice it
personally until a friend of ours Angel
um said something about it said look at
listen to your old vide listen old
videos Jenny she said and I was like oh
maybe I should so I went back and
listened to one I'm like oh my God yeah
my voice does part of it is an illusion
of this microphone though when I listen
to recordings of you your voice through
on the show sounds deeper than it does
in person in person okay okay so it may
have something to do with our audio I'm
not really bothered about it though it
doesn't [__] matter I don't give a
[__] Zach says I think a deep voice
works better with Jen's look kind of
Kathleen Turner sounding to me honestly
yeah that's something else is that uh
the uh female actresses if they're in
the Marvel MCU or they're they're on
gear too all right they're probably on
more gear than Jen gear does different
I'm not on a huge amount yeah no but
they're probably on more than her um it
it um deepens your voice
because testosterone or also anabolic
steroids to a lesser extent well don't
they thicken your uh thicken your vocal
cords your vocal cords that's all it is
that's all it is and it's temporary you
come off gear for a woman and for a man
but it would take longer it would slowly
start to thin out again I mean I was
never a huge fan of my voice to start
with yeah so if it changes I'm not
really I'm not married to it it's just
kind of like if it changes I'm not
really that worried about it you know
what I mean I never liked my voice
before I thought my voice sounded weird
and nasy yeah which maybe it still does
I don't know but no I thought it sounded
like like that before but it doesn't
really sound like that to me anymore
yeah there were a lot of porn stars in
the '90s that I L that I liked I thought
they had [__] kind of these raspy
voices and [__] and uh I didn't realize
it at the time but they were on [__] oh
you love when I whisper that [__] you're
like all kind of dirty [__] ass voice
yeah you you love when I whisper that
dirty ass [__] one of them was like um
one uh was
um was
her she's old now and she's still she's
still making video she looks pretty good
for her age
um
[__] I thought you were all up on on the
porn stars Tom come on you remembered
all their names and everything he
sometimes starts heartley he sometimes
starts talking about them like well I
know who Nina heartley is but sometimes
he starts talking about them like
they're people we know and I'm just like
who are you talking about Nina Harley he
remembers them all I don't nah Harley
she had the like of the best ass and
legs and porn all she seemed like a cool
chick I was she's still cool she's a
cool lady she's old as [__] but that's
cool yeah I've talked to her [__] uh
remember we talked to her yeah we were
talking about when we were cuz we were
live streaming and she was live
streaming at the same time and we were
like talking to her cuz we were bored if
you go back and look at Nina in the 80s
and the 90s she's on gear that's how
that legs and those asses got like that
and uh she was [__] she still looks
good she still looks good and she's on
stuff she's on and off stuff the time
she's old lady now she's [__] 60s
early 70s maybe 64 says 64 okay
she still streams she's stream she was
stre she was streaming when we were
streaming one time because we were
talking sending her [__] messages and
[__] just come like she oh you guys look
great you know what I mean yeah she came
over I was like oh my God she's famous
yeah yeah yeah she's going like make
sure you make sure time make sure you
you have special time for yourselves cuz
this is yeah she gave us a bunch of
advice yeah make sure special you can't
do this [__] for a living all the time
you got to [__] step away from cuz
like I said it's not really the same as
like yeah it's not the same spending
actual time together it's cuz you kind
of got to perform you know what I mean
you got to do [__] that other people
want to see you do and it's like you got
to make sure everything looks good for
the camera angles and stuff like that so
you can't do stuff that you would
normally just yeah so I just I'm always
into Men's Health and I always talk
about Men's Health on the show when I
can when I have time promote the
promotion of test and hormone
replacement because it's common it's
common in Show Business and it's
starting to be a lot more accepted okay
was more of a fo p in the [__] 70s
and the 80s but people didn't know it
was hard to disseminate information back
then about how the human body worked and
I feel like people did it but like they
it was like ghost to like say that they
were doing it they weren't saying it
yeah cuz like you're supposed to no I
just look like this naturally this is
all natural yeah yeah no yeah sure no
not once you're our
age that's that's not how that works
like I said I have good jeans okay but
that'll only take you so far that'll
only take you so far okay well guess
what Jen it's time it's about time to go
DVD Dragon says you see the voice of a
sexy woman on gear is different from a
square yeah yeah exactly exactly like I
said go back and listen to Kim card's
Betty Davis eyes that chick's on gear
yeah that's how she got that voice some
women do have that voice just naturally
she's on gear but yeah I don't know I
kind of like it I can do phone TX now if
I wanted oh yeah you could do phone sex
easy how are you doing you got to be a
[__] I should start smoking
yeah yeah I'll start smoking again so I
can get that like smoker R exactly got
be then I could just be like hey what
are you doing yeah no now I sound like
like an old bat
that's there's just come here and give
me a kiss yeah well they have voice
lessons you know for the
stage fig out
right Karen says she's 64 65 in May okay
well post us some pictures damn it how
hot are you 65 anybody could be 65 are
you hot at her and her husband broke the
bed they broke the bed too we also broke
a bed yeah okay we need to get another
one like you can still sleep in it
but it's um it's getting ready to
collapse yeah [__] uh [__] they
got it was making all kind of [__]
they got girls in their 70s in porn that
are hot what's her name D'Angelo yeah
what was her name [__] uh was that
the one you showed me with like the two
old ladies in the tub and yeah two
ladies in the tub with the [__] young
black dude fight fighting over that dick
like what was her name something other
D'Angelo Beverly D'Angelo no uh no that
was the that was the woman that was in
yeah yeah that was in the vacation
movies yeah [__] Sally okay Sally
Sally D'Angelo go look at her I think
she's
75 she's [__] like a wicked witch but
there's something just hot about her the
big old fake titties Tom likes the
wicked witch well if I get like super
super old yeah like if you're still
around when I'm 90 I will lean into that
wicked witch cuz that is [__] awesome
get you some [__] triple f [__]
implants and [__] I'll put like some big
[__] fingernails on like people
come oh I'm I'm I'm all about it yeah
get off my lawn I'm excited about that
actually Sally with her liver spots yeah
she's got liver spots on her hands and
[__] big [__] pumpkin siiz titties
and [__] one point in one way and one
point of the other [__] skiny ass
come
here she's hot though there's something
[__] hot give Grandma a bourbon big
old [__] dick I can do that I can do
that I can do granny
porn just like an evil old witch I love
it I love it throwing a
[__] then like taking advantage of
young girls and [__] on video like see I
can totally do that evil old Wicked wit
and like I said like the older I got
like ESP special like I would lean into
it I would I would do some [__] like I
would do some [__] like um uh what's the
[__] name yeah the dude that does the
The Goth music that like does the what
is the name
God damn it so turnis sois yeah and uh
yeah s with her [__]
biker Sally with a [__] yeah Sally
D'Angelo that chick man for 70 something
she's [__] sounds like he was showing
that to me he's like look this [__] 7
[__] four man and she's still
throwing down she I respect doing Studio
porn mainstream Studio porn there is a
market for it clearly man handling young
dudes and [__] doing that telling
them young girls the [__] throw your
legs back over your [__] head you
know just like yeah that's right you
tell them young [__] what to
do yeah it would be do they have any of
her like pegging 25y old you could find
something I'm sure I'm sure she's done
that I want to see like an old lady a
girl that works with her actually
pegging like a 25-year-old dude that'd
be [__] awesome the girl or stepping
on his nuts that'd be cool too her main
sidekicked uh [__] my buddy's wife in
the oh that's right you told me that
yeah yeah so I can get a hold a half of
that act I might be I might be able to
track Sally down she might be living
around here for all I know we could do a
whole thing with that I get Sally on a
show fill the T come there you yeah yeah
yeah see I love that yeah in a way I'm
kind of like looking forward to being an
old lady I can get away I could get away
with all kind of stuff wi witch on the
[__] show I get away with all kind of
stuff trying to get us go down on her
yeah all right you ready sure okay I'll
be on one side you be on the other okay
let's goad and shut it down we got to go
we got to go yeah Karen said uh yes I
can do the voice my hubby says I'm hot
and that's what matters see yeah that's
all that matters man just find somebody
that's like your person that's what you
got to do hard to do but you can all get
there you can all get there all right we
got to head out cuz we're going out to
the club tonight hopefully they play
some good music and I can dance and [__]
like that and uh yeah so remember to
come back have a good weekend everybody
first and then Monday we'll be back
we're going to be talking about the Ed
because sent us that he also sent us
come and see which we are also going to
watch but we're going to do that like
the week after CU we got to do the
parted he sent us that one first so
we're going to be talking about The
Departed on Monday so hopefully you guys
can join us for that thank you for
dropping by this evening hopefully you
guys have a good weekend and we'll see
you guys again on Monday night good
night